also den Filter Mach ich auf jeden Fall
da kann man jeden triggern
grün
ich mal auf 5
gibt ja auf jeden Fall
Partei der was auch immer.
okay kenn ich gar nich.
will die aber nich auf 10 setzen.
ich setz dich mal auf 9 weil kenn ich halt einfach nich
freie Wähler. boah schwierig 7
na schwierig boah
MH 6
MH auf
43.
ich bewert nur die Parteien
ne die nich die einzelnen äh
hier abgeordnet und das wär n bisschen
frech. boah ich weiß nich OB was Schlimmeres kommt.
das schon sehr sehr sehr große
Scheiße.
boah würd ich niemals auf 2 setzen. muss ich jetzt aber
ja komm die ist zwar ne spaßverteil
setz ich aber lieber auf 1 als
die AfD. die kommt auf die 10.